there is only one conor mcgregor and he  is your new  featherweight world champion connor 13  seconds we have confirmed  it is the fastest finish in a title  fight ever in ufc history  how do you feel right now i feel  clean i feel like my work  has paid off your state of zen certainly  paid off as well this week  it took very little energy to finish  that fight tell me how you saw that  opening and what you landed i just  wanted to enjoy it you know  a lot of people a lot of people force  their shots and  i think i honestly believe power is an  illusion it's  the perception of power is like if it's  tense and squeezed but to me that's  that can be seen a mile away so i just  like to place  and just just let it go it's four  ounce gloves you just need to tip the  chin and that's it  well it's